well for those of you watching on
peacock we just got a little bit of a
surprise there
profanity from chris sims uh oh here's
tom brady on play until 50. uh oh that's
a long time even for me that's a long
time i've always said 45 was the age
that i wanted to reach and that was my
goal this year i'll be 44. so next year
wait for it i'll be 45. i've got a
two-year contract i'm going to be able
to obviously play this year and god
forbid anything happens but play next
year and then see what happens
after that if i still want to keep
playing i might be able to do that and
if that's enough then that would be
enough i think he keeps going chris i
just i think he keeps going
and uh
i i don't think he makes it to 50 but i
don't think he stops at 45 either but he
stops at number 10. he's in the top 10
at number 10 on the chris sims top 40
quarterback countdown plenty of people
are triggered by that they think he
should be number one or close to it oh
yeah why do you have a number two well
that's every year though whoever's in
the super bowl should be one or two
people went crazy when the rams were in
the super bowl and i made jared goff 19.
now no one banks bats and i when he's 31
in football like nobody even cares you
know it's it's the logic there is not
always correct tom brady's awesome now
again i do my list
mike just to re-emphasize here it is
everybody's playing on the same offense
okay it's my pecking order it is you
know my depth chart at the quarterback
position so you don't get the benefit of
the best weapons and the best offensive
line and the best defense on your team
to make you look that way okay because
average supporting cash right it's all
average right now having said all that
brady was awesome last year he was
absolutely awesome different brady big
arm big throws power throws aggressive
you know got down in the red zone made a
lot of big time throws down there that's
where it was amazing and that's where
like man i just can't respect tom brady
enough the fact that you know the two
years prior to that in new england we
were all talking about oh he just he's
unwilling to stand in the pocket or make
some of the aggressive throws he's
always taking the easier throw or the
higher percentage throw which yeah is
good but of course can lead to leaving
plays and points and yards out in the
field he didn't do that very much last
year that's where he was special okay
and of course at the end of the year it
really took off really for me when i
went back and watched it's the second
half of the atlanta game when they were
down i want to say 17 something nothing
at halftime and he came back that's
where the offense took off brady took
off and everything like that and that's
where they became special so uh it is
amazing and it's amazing that bruce
arians and leftwich got brady to change
his mindset and be more aggressive that
way his arm is still top-notch as we've
talked about
there's no doubt about that and gosh i
wouldn't be shocked if he was back in
the super bowl again this year but not
the number so why are there number two
or number two why why yeah are there
nine in front of him now because tom
brady makes almost zero plays off
schedule okay almost zero there's
there's none of that now he moves in the
pocket well yes we know that but to an
extent it's to an extent i mean tom
brady again when we go back and i really
studied it again you know listen i know
we can always blame the quarterback for
losing a football game
the bucks lost five games because of tom
brady i can go through the other great
quarterbacks and go yeah they might have
lost one or two games because of them
maybe they didn't play their best and
they didn't win the game but they didn't
lose the game because of that you go
through both new orleans games the bears
game
okay the rams game the kansas city game
there was blitzes and aaron and pressure
around him and errant and bad and stupid
throws where
he made horrible decisions and that's
why they lost the game let alone like we
saw the meltdown in the nfc championship
game where if they lose that game to
your point like a week ago we're all
going i don't know does tom brady still
have it is he still the same tom brady i
mean if matt lafleur goes forward on
fourth down and somehow green bay wins
that game that's what we're talking
about this year we're not going oh my
gosh he's the second best quarterback in
football no
so
that's where it comes into it he's
awesome but he needs a certain type of
formula around him
i do give him credit he's not as good as
ryan tannehill and justin herbert who
are behind him but i gave him the boost
in front of them because of leadership
belief edginess experience the thing he
does for the football team but if i put
him in situations that some of these
other quarterbacks were in
with lack of weapons or lack of
protection come on get out of here
everybody so all you idiots on twitter
whoever else keep at me he's number ten
i know more than you and shut up there
we go let me just emphasize this point
always very humble from chris simmons
let me emphasize this point if the
packers pull off the come-from-behind
win down 28-10 fueled by
three occasions where
instead of even trying to make an
off-schedule throw it was suck-and-chuck
just get rid of right get rid of the
ball before i get hit right he he
reached that point a few years ago and
that's fine that's fine look it takes a
tremendous amount of courage at any age
to play nfl
when you're on the wrong side of 40 and
and there are guys younger faster and
stronger than you that would love
nothing more than to then to turn your
body into multiple pieces that need to
be put back together again you do what
you have to cancer you do what you can
to survive yeah and uh it's not just
that he can't make the off off-schedule
throw it's when it all falls apart he's
prone to a turnover exactly just has to
get rid of the football right just get
rid of it if it gets picked off so be it
happened three times in a row
and yeah i think people would be saying
10 is too high if the packers had won
that game based upon the way brandon
played in that game and then you take
away the super bowl appearance that
actually boosts his estimation right
you've been somewhere between between 12
and 15. exactly you know i mean yes that
and again that's not disrespect i mean
again i think it's just keeping it real
here i don't it doesn't make me proud to
say this i know brady's awesome i know
that he's amazing but at age 43 he
cannot do some of the things that we
talk about so often on this show that
some of these guys in front of them can
do but but yes there's definite value to
like you know the stuff you brought up
so much time his belief he gave he was
just the right guy for that team he
really was they needed a little polish
somebody to push them in the right
direction you know just the right jerk
at the quarterback position to get
everybody on edge a little bit and
that's where he was perfect for the
tampa bay buccaneers there's no doubt
about that um you know he's the man and
i understand his go his goatness is
always on the top of my mind but yeah
for me right now he's and i don't mean
to be cocky and a jerk i understand i
know more than you i'm being a jerk i
get frustrated with twitter and all that
sometimes not everybody has to agree
with me but
i don't i i just i can't realistically
look at it at all where i will fight
back because when people go oh i think
he's still top five that's where i just
want to like brain emoji blow up you're
crazy no you know i mean anywhere from
eight to twelve i think you can make a
case for for tom brady for me he's
number ten
the intangibles are critical and this is
why i believe that
that you know you've got you've got the
folks out there who refuse to ever
concede any point remotely close to the
notion
that wins count as quarterback stats
great quarterbacks who are great leaders
can influence a team to win games that
otherwise would have lost because the
influence goes so far beyond the
decisions you make with the football and
where you actually throw the ball and
whether you do it accurately and with
sufficient velocity for example two
things that stand out for me one
leading up to the super bowl every night
yeah texting amazing teammate we will
win right we will win getting them all
to believe we will win and he's got the
cachet he's got the credentials he's got
the pelts on the wall and or
pelts on the horse or whatever the hell
the right saying is and the one i like
even more than that
they win the nfc championship they're in
the locker room after the game devin
white told this story somebody was
crying because they'd won the nfc
championship game
and brady accosted the guy
berated him
dropping profanity on him
now isn't the time you cry we still got
more work to do right that's the
difference between a tom brady and
anyone else no doubt about it there's no
doubt that's where he was just the right
fit for this football team and what they
needed we knew how talented they were i
mean we were in miami the year before it
still jumps out to me with matt ryan at
that super bowl right with the chiefs of
the 49ers i can remember him talking
about that buccaneers team and how
talented they were and it made me like
think about it a little bit and go you
know
maybe they are more talented he was like
man they're one of the best teams we
played last year and all that so they
just needed that brady factor and that's
where he's special and there's no doubt
about it his arm is still
like top-notch some of those throws he
made in the super bowl some of the other
throws we saw towards the end of the
season i mean laser beams for 43 years
old 42 whatever amazing but yes 10
because
yes if things do break down
more bad than good happens he's not
going to get out of the pocket and make
something happen in fact when things
break down like you mentioned before
he's going to kind of fall away fade and
just throw the ball and get it out of
his hands and that led to if people go
back and watch some crazy interceptions
during this year that led to the their
five losses but man his clutch belief
edginess all that certainly helped them
win the super bowl there's no doubt to
your point pete reminded me of the third
story i liked from last year when devin
white was snubbed for the pro bowl and
was grousing about it brady said to him
basically
why do you care
that's not the game we're trying to get
to devon we're trying to get to the
super bowl and again you have to be
brady to pull it off but he's got
he's got the ability and the willingness
to make it work that's one of the big
reasons why the buccaneers won the super
bowl
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports